ask a group of unrelated people how all
the life in the universe was created and
they would each probably give you a
different answer ask someone with a
scientific background and they'll tell
you the universe was birthed after the
big bang and that life gradually evolved
on earth over millions of years or if
you were to ask someone of the christian
faith they might tell you that god
created the entire universe in six days
every planet star even giving life to
every single creature then took sunday
off every belief system since the dawn
of humanity whether monotheistic
pantheistic or even atheistic have had
their own creation stories and myths and
then there's the answer that a member of
the church of the broken god would give
you and trust us it's far more
complicated just in case you've never
heard them mention before the church of
the broken god is an anomalous religious
organization and group of interest the
scp foundation has actually had a number
of encounters with the church over the
years and we'll get to why that is in a
moment members of the church share in
the belief that life specifically
biological flesh-based life like that of
human beings is inherently wrong a
direct product of evil their religion
focuses on the worship of mechanization
which is the process of making something
or someone more mechanical in nature so
what do members of the church believe
created life in the universe
well according to their beliefs in the
beginning there were two ancient and
powerful beings named yaldabach and
meccan who created humanity together
yaldabath was the god of flesh and
animal instinct granting human bodies
while mccain the god of machine and
intellect blessed man with the power of
free thought as humankind developed its
civilization began building machines
this enraged yaldabaoth seeing that the
humans were ignoring the instincts she
had bestowed upon them as a result she
swore to destroy all the creations of
man seeking to revert them back to the
animalistic state she had intended for
them according to the church's legend
mccain acted as humanity's savior and
intervened to stop yaldabah the god of
machine shattered himself transforming
his metal body into a number of pieces
to form a cage for his fellow god these
fragments of meccan's body rain down on
planet earth scattered and lost the
church of the broken god believes it is
their duty their only true purpose to
recover those pieces as such the church
is devoted to the worship of meccan
their broken god that lies in fragments
scattered across the world often using
anomalous technology members of the
church of the broken god intend to
uncover or steal these various
components the church's ultimate goal is
to bring the correct pieces together and
eventually restore mccain's form it is
their hope that he will guide them to
intellectual enlightenment and bless
them with new mechanical forms so that
they can discard their mortal bodies of
flesh and blood and ascend to a fully
mechanized way of life the one problem
is that there could be potentially
hundreds of pieces required in order to
rebuild meccan he cannot lead the church
to glory and defeat yeldebath once and
for all with parts still missing a
number of these pieces have already
surfaced as catalogued scps that the
foundation is either aware of or has in
containment among them are scp-882
or his broken heart to the church
scp-270
his broken gift
scp-813 has broken eyes
scp-1139 his broken tongue
scp-635 his broken mind and finally his
broken blood which refers to scp-217
and then there's scp-3179
sometimes referred to as the seed in
1909 a meteor shower reigned over
dellington a tiny village in england but
something else fell with the meteors
something otherworldly it was made out
of liquid metal its form constantly
shifting and shimmering never staying at
the same mass or held in the same shape
for long the object whatever it was
quickly fell into the possession of a
group known as the cogwork orthodoxy you
see within the religion of the church of
the broken god there exists a number of
splinter factions that ironically broke
away from the main church one such group
referred to as the cogwork orthodox
church augment their own bodies through
mechanical implants however we aren't
talking microchips the cogwork orthodox
church will only use technology from the
late industrial revolution as they think
it is more fitting of their god meccan
so what does this object
scp-3179 have to do with all these tales
of mechanical churches and broken gods
scp-3179 is capable of extending its
mass forming long rod-like metal
structures that protrude from its
central mass these rods are then used to
create smaller entities referred to as
scp-3179-1
these entities might lack the ability to
expand or change shape the same way that
scp-3179
can but they are specialized for a wide
range of functions the
scp-3179-1 creations are usually
designed to help free
scp-3179 from its containment and will
obey this purpose without exception yet
somehow they do not appear capable of
communicating with the main body that
they were created from while
scp-3179 remains as a constant mass of
liquid metal the entities it creates are
able to simulate an exterior organic
appearance in other words
they look like they are alive still
struggling to find out why the cogwork
orthodoxy and the church of the broken
god would be so interested in this thing
well maybe this will answer that burning
question warranty silas one of the
members of the cogwork orthodoxy that
recovered scp-3179
the metallic object was the seed of
meccan according to the beliefs of the
church this liquid metal entity would
one day expand to form the offspring of
their broken god perhaps hoping to
protect the future child of their
faith's deity the cogwork orthodoxy
constructed a containment bunker around
scp-3179 in 1917.
at first this sturdy container seemed to
have done its job possibly having even
been made using anomalous methods or
properties to keep
scp-3179 in place for over a hundred
years it successfully held the entity
and restricted its ability to grow
however the unit has since been damaged
by multiple attempts by the entity to
breach its containment and will likely
fail completely within the next five
years you see
scp-3179 isn't just alive but sentient
the liquid metal entity has displayed an
extremely high level of intelligence
although not through direct
communication it shows its intelligence
through its evolving tactics changing
the shape of its mass or creating more
instances of scp-3179
to aid in its escape in fact the
so-called seed of meccan is so vastly
intelligent in its strategies and
relentless in its goal to breach its
containment that in 2016 most of the
containment unit built around it had
been destroyed the cogwork orthodoxy had
no choice but to directly contact the
scp foundation and appeal to them to
take over the containment of scp-3179
even after this exchange the foundation
still had significant trouble keeping
the entity contained they couldn't
transport it instead assigning a mobile
task force zeta 10 codenamed death metal
to monitor
scp-3179's growth if a section of its
body expanded too far beyond an
acceptable level these personnel had to
step in and sever it from the main body
of scp-3179
any parts sliced severed or otherwise
removed from the liquid metal mass still
continues to grow for several hours
after its removal however this growth
eventually stops and these pieces are
left inert and lifeless for example on
one occasion in late december of 2016
scp-3179 grew a number of metal supports
from its main body not unlike multiple
pairs of legs before the entity could
use these new appendages to pull itself
free and escape its containment members
of mtf death metal stepped in and
severed them before they could fully
grow a few weeks later in january of
2017
scp-3179 tried a similar strategy
growing structures resembling propellers
on top of its body and attempting to
attain flight once again death metal did
what they do best and clipped
scp-3179's wings it later produced
instances of
scp-3179-1 in the form of numerous
flying drones that it tried to use to
fly away from the containment zone mtf
zeta 10 was able to shoot these entities
down forcing
scp-3179 to once again alter its tactics
next it produced a number of sound
emitting structures from its central
mass and used them to mimic the voices
of a number of mtf zeta 10 members the
metallic creature attempted to plead
with the foundation's operatives in the
voices of their colleagues claiming that
they had become trapped inside the
liquid metal after no result a day later
scp-3179 began to use the same
structures to emit screams of the same
mtf zeta 10 troops this time the voices
claimed that
scp-3179 was killing them and begged to
be set free once again the foundation's
personnel remained at their posts though
this breach attempt apparently added a
lot more job stress to the role
scp-3179 even on multiple occasions
produced instances of
scp-3179-1 that were identical to
existing mtf zeta 10 members trying to
convince the others that the entity
should be released from its containment
zone at one point it was even able to
use tiny
scp-3179-1s to replace the internal
organs of one of the mtf zeta 10 members
in his sleep with entirely mechanical
components on the outside the man looked
to be human his eyes skin and tongue all
organic but inside he had been made a
puppet of
scp-3179 and sent off to sabotage a
number of systems involved in the
entity's containment luckily the
foundation's forces were able to stop
this new instance of scp-3179-1
and terminated him of course this all
begs the question why would the cogwork
orthodoxy hand
scp-3179 over to the foundation if the
seed of meccan was so sacred to them so
important to their belief system then
why give it to another organization you
could argue that the cogwork orthodoxy
were admitting that they weren't as well
equipped as the foundation are when it
comes to containing anomalies or that
they'd rather the future offspring of
meccan was best kept as safe as possible
but that is if you even believe that
scp-3179
really is the seed of meccan while
growing in its containment the entity
showed to be considerably hostile
towards the members of the church that
curated it it even caused a number of
casualties killing many that wanted to
protect it on behalf of meccan
additionally the metallic mass wouldn't
change its state whenever they would
read scripture related to the broken god
in fact it showed little reaction at all
to any displays of faith from the
cogwork orthodoxy surely mccain's own
offspring wouldn't have behaved in such
a way unless of course scp-317
wasn't the seed of meccan at all what if
this entity was an imposter oblivious of
the beliefs of the church of the broken
god and given how intelligent it had
shown itself to be surely scp 3179 would
know to take advantage of the faith of
those that had tried to procure it on
the 2nd of june 2017
scp-3179 produced a number of metal
tablets from itself and dispersed them
throughout the containment area
surrounding it each tablet had the same
inscription written on it humans must
obey the ruling of gods the meccan is a
god the meccan is a powerful entity of
steel and industry i am a powerful
entity of steel and industry
therefore
i am meccan
therefore
i
am a god
therefore
you
will release me it is entirely possible
that
scp-3179 was indeed a part of mccain the
ancient broken god and deity to the
church and the cogwork orthodoxy but
then again this entity showed
intelligence and adaptability as well as
hostility towards the human beings
around it perhaps this so-called seed of
meccan was nothing more than a false
prophet trying to use the faith of the
church to ensure its own escape it
doesn't get much craftier than that now
go check out
scp-001 the broken god or borah cycle
and what actually happened to major
alexi belatrov
scp-2273 tale for more lore from the
church of the broken god